I wanted to talk to you bout something I
heard you say this I can't remember
where I heard you say it but it's
something that I have long maintained
and I'm glad that I found someone else
with the same belief system which is
that I heard you say men should never
wear shorts yes I agree thank you thank
you I it now I'm fine with ski no kids
wear shorts kids can quit grown men
grown men should not wear shorts in
public they can wear mitt to be us to
place the beach and and the pool yeah I
guess the only two places they should
really be seeing shorts right you know
and flip-flops
absolutely not unless you're one of
those two places here in California you
go to funeral
and there are people there in shorts and
black shorts and black flip-flop yeah
and they're drinking the bit the beer
cozy is black so it's very like you know
there's a funeral I know why I'm sure
yeah exactly but it's the same thing
where people where Andy you don't agree
with this dude I don't agree with this
at all no I feel like a week ago in
shorts I was wearing short candy where I
wouldn't even look below this way I live
in Los Angeles
and I work like he said on pee-wee's
Playhouse yeah why not dress like a
toddler yeah why why should I do wear
dress it anyway other than like to admit
there is some and maybe this is a little
me playing my hand Andy you got a nice
set of legs on you you with any shorts
that's the other thing this little light
of mine I'm gonna let it shine yeah
Tuscon you famously you stay in really
good shape you would look at it shorts I
don't wear shorts because it doesn't
look so good I think it's a very skinny
like so what's it covered in tattoos
that's where I do all my experimental
tattoos are down on my legs literally
like I have a tattoo that I don't wanna
commit to I'll just stick it on my legs
because I know no one's gonna see em
everything you put you tattoo stuff on
your body that you're not sure about
yeah it's freaking it's gonna like pass
the test and work its way from your calf
check there's some of my favorite tattoo
throughout my legs yeah that's crazy
wait a minute but I would think you
would be really certain before you you
know you can't put much thought into it
otherwise you won't do it yeah yeah
you've got the Harry Styles you know
Harry sounds forever right on your leg
like I don't know now I really wish we
had like a gang of thugs so I could see
get his pants boys let's take a look at
those tats put him in sure yeah yeah and
he always wants to tear men's pants yeah
yeah
you